what's up bull what's up fool chillin
right here da was so full podcast yeah
man
brought you by all things comedy
Austin's Comedy Network what's up
everybody
we're here man we're a video taping a
podcast so you could see all of us could
see how how we do it you know the behind
the scenes also we have bomb and we
could just tell everybody right now to
go to Felipe's world.com that's my
webpage
Felipe's worldcom and then on Flippa
world.com you know we have a podcast
page on the podcast on the on the a
podcast page on the web page
yes but they're people you could see the
behind the scene photos oh yeah
everything for everything bro like you
getting ready for it to throw in the
laughs you are practicing your leg
remember everything but do we doing
push-ups you know we're improvising it
me over there the back order stealing a
coffee cup funny employees you know
things like that but another also pays
us merchandise
there's tours there's um but if you go
to the podcast one you can see all the
podcast that we ever did I know like
something on I - they don't list all of
them no more so all the episodes you can
get them if you want all the episode
ready to go all you can everything man
ethical and also on we have a web series
that's coming out called the shop and
you can see that also on our Philebus
world webpage and it's produced by our
things comedy so all the info for
Philippe in on the podcast web cast on
Philippe is worldcom you and the
speaking of this job we also have a shop
on the web page where you can buy you
the what's a full part cat hats and also
that the paintings are what's a full
podcast photograph the one with me
holding the headphones and front of the
60 bridge and that piece head was done
by Ernesto year and
the poster the poster that you sign man
and all that money for those posters go
for some art class and else central you
know cuz any class enough central man
because all the everybody that just
draws deserts bro and how many pictures
of cactus are you gonna have bronze and
a wastage you know gonna waste this and
I don't know man yeah man so most of the
money for these poster they go for this
art class you know for artists
and they get to learn how to paint on
stuff other than water you know and
dates oh yeah
and palm trees also man if you wanna buy
stuff not from us or from anybody just
say you want to download stuff from
Amazon just go to Philly people world
page now and just go through our amazon
link right there and you just get it
through there man game and we don't get
nothing out of it it's totally free this
all free stuff then you can do to help
us keep the podcast point we're gonna
stop going man but we'll just keep doing
it man spread the word
I don't want to beg like a daughter of
jazz stations and use a spacious I've
been listening to all my god by the way
make a $10 donation 100 donation a
thousand dollar donation whatever you
can do it yeah we're gonna have the Jazz
Caravan and we're gonna have a full load
of over 50 people deep and everybody's
gonna have Angela Johnson free DVD
Johnson just donated five sharone's we
won't say how much as Joe Johnston's
donated to the Jazz Festival we're just
trying to keep this this substation
going now we're here the all things jazz
our state most shows are one hour long
our shows only 12 men so we're almost
off the air but if you give us the
donation it'll be an arrow no we're
gonna spread this um yeah the jazz
Caravan we rehearsed we got a team top
20 not nothing the winter we have his um
his cousin a guy that he got they kicked
out of the band you know when he plays
bongos too but Tito Puente said it's
only one Bongo player for what's wrong
with you hit that team volley yeah also
um Tierra I won't be there not I should
Tierra um the other brother you know
they broke up there's two Tierra there's
Tara one and Tierra to the fourth man
whose true theater there is right yeah
let you said there was two temptations
and zap and run all that [ __ ] yeah
remember watching zap yeah no razor no
how original
dude it was a computer love bro some
computer love but how does [ __ ] okay
now dude I'm [ __ ] stumped I don't all
right people
all right man awesome show quick
shoutouts to arm row Helio Vasquez real
from Fontana he just figure out what a
podcast is a downloaded SoundCloud some
people that take you man I think you out
there man for telling people what a
podcast is and bringing them all to
listeners it was tough in the beginning
huh I couldn't really say podcast I will
tell people we have a radio station on
the Internet yeah internet radio show
you tell people cuz still a lot of
people don't know if whoo what a podcast
also of man verified coop from Canada he
promotes my show on periscope and he has
a big Canadian flag and this guy I don't
know what he does but he just just in
front of his porch he's in the Canadian
flag he drew it a big-ass hello here the
bong and he's his sister and he just
pontificate verifier coop what's up you
and your little chuckle meet here
hell yeah yes i curly her is I like that
curly like mine and Koo
it's just curly like William Shatner you
know like I like black people say you
got that good hair no man here's a conch
conky's from Canada dog so we're so fool
but we have a guest today man yeah
because the richer the rate the Raiders
are two and one now so we gotta have a
guest
rate or related and also because Latino
Hispanic Heritage Month
Heritage Month maybe wait we got a week
now bro oh yeah they should be Latino
Hispanic week now is Heritage Month bro
oh yeah I used to be singular mile now
was able to love school dances in your
pilot from Flo Corie cool yeah man and
then it was funny my other other guys
used to go wash their hands but
after holding the girl's hand me I used
to hold my face I never did that though
I never lie no I swear when I was a kid
I used to chase around these to have
black chicks are just kissing all the
time what happy women bro no I just want
one girl there's no more time to play we
got to be good bro
oh man so we're all right we are a guest
today bro ah all the way from San Jose
by way of Sam Bruno and she's sitting in
the right position right there she cool
you can see her alrighty so we're way
over here now the real realization
what's up people we have Angela Johnson
I'll put a receipt over there oh yeah
yeah producer and we have Angela Johnson
right here
Rex Rader and brought you to do wild
coyotes and Gotham's yes well so much
you know how you been good how are you
good good to see you good to see you man
how's the tour going that not ending
tour by the way yeah it's always
happening
it is just you know I don't have a tour
like some comedians do and a lot of
musicians do or they're on the the
such-and-such tour or whatever it is I
don't have that I just booked dates and
go and then my material gradually
changes me too man people we see people
like after the show table you man
how long is your tour and they say
there's no tour Matt wanted me here yeah
pool tables are gonna be here yeah so
yeah I'm on the road always come from
San Jose right yeah born and raised San
Jose but I've been living in LA for 13
years and then I met you shortly after I
moved here probably in 2006 I moved here
2003 2003 right but I started doing
stand-up at 2006 so that's what I met
you yes I remember meeting you man never
forget dude I booked her at my show for
tequila - yes and I give her $50
I didn't give her the money because I
don't know why there were no money and I
told her that I'm looking for the money
tomorrow
but then tomorrow never came and then
she hit me up on myspace a man I don't
wanna be on but could have a $50 and I
felt bad you know because I usually pay
that to all the women community before
the guys gentleman I felt so bad I said
no man will give you the money man
meet me in in LA so she met me at some
some Filipino cafe and we split a
chicken adobo sandwich remember this
story at all I never had that sandwich
before you said you knew it was that
trusted you with it
I do remember she took the onions out
that's all right good I was hooked after
that after that I said every Filipino
there that I knew I'd have it it was the
one I simply gotta have this dog Angela
Johnson give me a thumbs up so as long
as you take the onions out terrible
memory oh man hard do so this is
something that bothers every comedian
specialist someone like Angela Johnson
what's that for I was that there through
comedy works everybody and their mother
was showing up talking about kind of
hang on a green rule can I get a guest
spot comics and [ __ ] ah did you go to
that in the beginning like every my
everybody that gave you a bone wanting a
guest spot or J will show up infinity oh
you thought they'd come on Angela you
know I feel like in the beginning I
didn't know what was happening because I
usually it happened so fast for me I
didn't know the way things worked I
didn't know protocol I didn't know how
do I would just kind of thrown into this
situation and learning as I went so I
may have experienced some of that and
not even known it and just took it I was
like oh so and so wants to hang out or
something but I I can't even I don't
even remember it I just remembers all
happening all so fast at the same time
that it was like I took it as help yeah
I remember you DJ couch uh richer via so
many people helping me and just kind of
like giving me spots and and kind of
showing me the ropes because I had no
idea what I was doing I just knew I knew
how to do a Vietnamese accent and let's
go that's it that was crazy man because
that was um in 2006 that when you sign
with a manager right I thought that's
you know laughs festival in LA
oh yeah I had an agent uh-huh that's
when I got my agent uh-huh I remember
that day man good memory she and I was
gonna toast a bagel
all right I know I remember laughs first
of all only because um because you were
there and you got signed I knew you got
signed but also because I was being also
drunk and they brought a limousine to
pick me up to do a ten-minute set I said
what never I was a waste 38 but I didn't
know with a waster 40 now none of my
past were feeding and had the limousine
guy drive me to Ross and wait to I put
on pants that fit and never forget that
so fact you know yelling I feel like you
don't forget anything and my pet was so
fat but there was a guy there at the
Latino laugh first of all that was in a
movie with The Big Lebowski and I was
like he was the most unknown person
there besides me and then I'm I was
starstruck
that's for calling everybody bro you
don't know this guy is leads ghost I
remember when you started when um how do
they happen man um how much the people
team the people thing right away you
were a millionaire once you started the
viral honey wouldn't you how did that
feel like something I put um I put jokes
up and they go viral like 7 million
people like yeah but uh how did it feel
like me did you see a coming right away
or somebody says Angela man you was just
an Oprah and now your video hilarious
yeah
that was pretty much how it happened I
okay one I didn't even put the video up
on YouTube still until this day I can't
tell you how YouTube works it blows my
mind I don't get it how many time yes
whoo yeah so so the video was up
magically and I just started getting
text messages and phone calls from
people and I remember my mom called me
one day and she was telling me hey your
cousin Kristy was at work and somebody
sent her an email with a video of you in
it and I was like what video what are
you talking about I still hadn't even
seen it myself so I didn't know what she
was talking about and that's kind of how
it started I started getting phone calls
from people saying hey somebody sent me
a video of you and this is right around
the time when it was so new to receive a
video in an email you know what I mean
like before that there was no YouTube
there was none of this so actually
watching videos yeah watching videos was
a new thing getting emailed the video
was exciting it was like oh wow I can
press play in my email and it happened
that's cool right so it was like perfect
timing of this very funny joke meets
opportunity and timing and it just like
flew like wildfire and I remember
MySpace is when it was all happening and
I remember logging into my myspace one
day mmm and there was pages and pages of
friend requests and messages from people
all over the place that I had never met
before and so this was like my first
introduction to people being a fan of me
and people reaching out to me who I
didn't know who they were and knowing
things about me and I remember is kind
of scary because people would message me
because they found stuff on the internet
about me I didn't know there was things
about me on the Internet at this point
you know what I mean and people be like
oh yeah you went to such-and-such school
and lived by blah blah blah and I'm like
whoa this is crazy who are these people
and why do they know all this stuff
about me so it was crazy in 2007 is when
that video came out I didn't even put it
up but it definitely blew up my spot and
changed the course of where my career
was going for sure that was so cool
lemon
like happen to you and when we had um we
have Russell Peters on the show he said
to his one-hour special went viral in
China like somebody somebody safety
happening him like it was the same time
your blew up his blew up in 2005 because
I remember I met him in 2005 and like
his special started blowing up wow that
was a big crazy man and they happened to
the right person - because you were well
grounded person comedian I'm pretty sure
that would happen to me probably be
sitting here bro a perimeter where
somewhere just whatever - Felipe ah man
that fool could have been here bro what
happened had 20 million views he'd do it
man he choked her something by Celia
broke Wow but what the earth I tell
people you know because we had Jimmy
Schubert here and he was talking about
he didn't really say names he was
talking about how people who go viral on
Varnum on vine
we are or Instagram they make these
little videos and then they push them to
do stand-up comedy yeah and they really
can't hack it right well you
I saw you man I saw you in San Jose you
know and um and I said and you had Jeff
Keith open for you man she was up to
like George Carlin bro without a yellow
no PAP paper bro
you know working that first one hour
like a soldier bro going up you know cuz
you know she knew she wasn't ready bro
cuz I remember she had al Madrigal open
for her and album and she was doing like
30 minutes they know I opened for him
but you were headlining it well okay the
first time I headlined they had to put 8
openers in front of me because I didn't
have enough material to headline a show
I was just basically during those times
yeah so this was in San Jose improv they
put up eight people ahead of me
Sean DISA Bush Escobar Chris Dorian that
big fat fool is name the fact that you
know this lineup is hilarious
be wary warm almost Kabir Burma Kabir
Sibelius people shallow when I'm there
and again this is like when I'm brand
new right and so they were like yeah oh
yeah then to headline the show and so I
don't know how anything works I remember
we sold out the San Jose Improv in the
sold tickets to my show and I got paid a
whopping five hundred dollars oh yeah
they did yeah I was it was fun and you
learn as you go as things like that it
was like oh and I remember thinking at
the time to I was like but all these
people came here and I only get five for
you and they paid to get you right okay
oh yeah oh yeah it was a paid show it
was a full paid show but this is I was
just starting and I only had 25 minutes
of material and so I didn't know how
things worked you know I didn't know
what deals were made I was just showing
up to close out the show and you know
learning as I go so how long did it take
you to do that to get to the 45 from the
do you know miraculously and I wish I
could write material as fast as I did
then but it was really about a year it
was a 2007 when that video took off and
I had maybe 12 minutes of material at
the time and so people will be like hey
when are you coming to Atlanta when are
you coming to Ohio and stuff like that
I'm like oh crap I have 12 minutes of
jokes I I don't know when I'm coming and
that's when I did that festival and I
ended up getting an agent which was it
was unheard of to get an agent when you
don't even have like a half hour of
material you know but something was
happening with this YouTube thing and
they knew that clubs were wanting me and
I remember DJ couch was actually helping
me he was booking some of my shows for
me and acting as an agent for me in the
beginning and so I ended up getting with
an actual agent and he took me on and he
would put me I had to open up for a few
headliners and this is gonna be unheard
it when you when you hear this it's
crazy but I really only featured three
times
in my entire career because I started
offending headliners is what it was
because again I didn't know what I was
doing but I would show up and they would
say okay you're gonna go do radio to
promote the weekend well I didn't know
features don't go do radio that's the
headliners job I don't know any of this
and how it works this is my first time
and so I would do the weekend with the
headliner and it would be most of the
people there were coming to see me
and so these headliners were getting
pretty offended and I didn't know what
to do how to handle it so I did it about
three times before they were like okay
let's try just giving her her own show
and put some people in front of her to
fill up the time and then I just started
writing as much as I could so that I
could do my own shows so is by the end
of the year I was doing my own shows so
it took me about a year to get to at
least 45 minutes of material which is
still crazy to write that much material
in a year oh yeah now it takes me oh I
don't know how long I'll go months
before I'm like I'll have anything to
say there's nothing going on in life you
know what I mean I don't have anything
to talk about but it's I don't know is
when the pressure was on you know and it
was like yeah let me do that but I I
really have only done full feature
weekends for Tom Rhodes al Madrigal and
Steve Trevino those are the only people
that I've ever really featured for yes
clubs clubs are sweet and they wonder
why Eddie Griffin wants why Air Force
Ones before every show I know about that
sneaky that's not even the hell
unethical all that pays a hell later
there's no radio those have no Halen and
that's what do radio no saying you is
there I know they did that for one
particular weekend and then a different
weekend they sent me with the headliner
and luckily this guy was very gracious
and I think he knew that I didn't know
what I was doing so I could tell that it
was hurtful for his pride for his ego
but he was very gracious with me and um
just kind of talked to me talk to me
through it a little bit and but that was
my first weekend out so he knew I was I
didn't know what I was doing but you
could tell it was it was a little sting
there and um but I I learned you know
and it was unfortunate because I think
people got upset with me but again like
I was like oh this is my second time
doing this I'm sorry interesting this is
the first time somebody has said that
they never featured that many times and
I believed them you met people I said I
will straight to headline standing
ovation of first time you brought your
family room it was a bringer theatre
show there's a practice in front of your
friends Club I remember you were blown
up you would do those Refresh Friday
yeah yeah don't be a line around the
block
would you get 25 bucks nothing huh yeah
no I don't remember yeah when I won last
Comic Standing people are trying to
approach me to do these shows but then
I'm Gabriel s he had told me just you
know you know what just turn your phone
off you're gonna get a lot of
opportunities to pour better shows but
people gonna call you into you man how
many titles Gabriel told me that a lot
of people were cops you got a man my
brother needs a limb man yeah do a
charity for him yeah you get a lot of
that a lot of charity requests for sure
I get people who are just I've never met
them and they're emailing my managers
and agents and stuff like that and then
hitting me up on Facebook and Twitter
and then I get people who I actually
know from back in the day wanted me to
do that as well and and it's still even
then it's like I can't do a charity show
every weekend even if we've met a couple
times it's still it's a hard balance you
know and and so i-i've allotted myself a
few charity events throughout the year
and and it's usually something that I've
either really believed in or it just
really struck a chord with my heart and
I'm like you know I'm gonna do this
for this person but I give myself a
certain amount so at that point when
people do come to me it's not like I
have to decide oh should I or shouldn't
I it's like oh I'm sorry I actually
booked up my my charity shows and I a
lot myself a certain amount because
again that's and a lot of times too if
you do in a like a competing market like
for instance Texas for some reason I am
so big in Texas
take me to Ohio not one person knows my
name there but Texas they love me right
and so I get a lot of people wanted me
to do charity there but at the same time
that's like my biggest market and if I
sacrifice my biggest market to do a
charity that's not a smart business move
you know so it's it's a lot of living
and learning and figuring out the whole
how it all works you know so you want to
do a charity people move your charity
from Texas Council Bluffs Iowa Ohio
anywhere in the Northeast I will do
every journey possible yes justice job
trying to put as you know Johnson with
another comedian Texas anything gonna
work you want to put over somebody put a
Toledo Ohio they date in Ohio yeah
anywhere so you started off like a lot
of comedians like you started out
working clean or now you just naturally
that we do stand-up comedy yeah that's
just naturally right yeah that's just
how I roll I my act is an exaggerated
version of my life you know
the way I talk the stories that I tell
all of my stories are based in truth and
then exaggerated for the sake of
storytelling you know but it's just the
way that I naturally talk and em so it
just ended up working that way for me I
didn't have to try to be clean comic
Rizzuto has this fake persona on stage
where he called women broads
I was high you said about 100 yeah it's
all about what I you started off as a
and naturally because that's the way you
are as your persona you know you don't
curse in a conversation but there's
comedians man who just work just for the
sake of working clean my you get more
working another dirty offstage I saw the
cleanest man on the stage or the
dirtiest person offstage dirtiest are
the most creepiest - we can we find the
Raider red photos hilarious everything's
on the internet Google how did you will
you always a Raider fan or did you just
I need a job man hilarious no if you
want a job don't be a cheerleader for
those don't be a professional
cheerleader period it's basically
volunteer work 85 bucks a game or less
eighty dollars a game yeah when I was a
cheerleader this 2002-2003 we were paid
eighty dollars a game and we were the
highest-paid cheerleaders in the NFL
damn
I'll Davis was breaking records on and
this stupid mascot I don't know for what
two years on he was two million dollars
a year man the Vikings that's kind of
just like the Viking he wants a contract
that he needs a fire contract that's
gonna pay him huh he was a 20-year card
why does he do that he's just like a
Viking I know a lot of high school kids
that would probably go for old man he
will need that work as a Viking he's one
of those guys from Citibank no for real
he wants a 20 year contract 20 year
contract to continue to be the Viking
for the Minnesota bike isn't his actual
face or is he in a costume like his
actual face oh I see
oh I see I mean really okay but listen
Julie
two more words I thought my my point is
good luck I wish you all the best
what's in your wallet nothing right now
here all week you know yes
no yeah we were the high speed trailers
and NFL game 2002 2003 when we went to
the Super Bowl
yes Tampa Bay in San Diego that year oh
yeah it was amazing year oh gee Riley
were so drunk and drunk so sad Willie
Barcena had to read them a hotel room
broke sad yeah dude don't do anything in
front of Felipe because he will remember
and talk about it on his podcast 13
years later I will getting drunk all
those times not most of you know tape
recorder yes watching the first time I
made you you walked into the wild
coyotes in Montebello with another
female comic or Puerto Rican woman yeah
Peruvian Peruvian yeah and you guys did
a spy and I remember you killed it with
that Neil bit yeah as long as I could do
that nail bed the time cool it was yeah
dude like only two people have killed it
like that in the beginning at that show
I mean that's all rough man and we let
the Mexican Apollo oh God oh boy you're
bad man and now only gayer Iglesias was
the last first person ever where but it
was like wow and then this you know you
see him on TV go oh yeah man that guy is
to eat ribs here chicken man um we were
the two years ago when I was in
2011-2012 and uh at the end of the my
account the end of the mine a Mayan
calendar there it is
I almost bury rumors
radio stations that nah man he goes the
world's gonna end I said yeah bro the
world's gonna end man there's gonna be a
big comedy show with parrot Regas George
Lopez Angela Johnson and Felipe Esparza
bro the end of the world tour $150 take
it bro yeah only for true ballers
alcohol will be sold outside the theater
hey George get that out you know what
people get too drunk in shows so rarely
so I don't know people dig in Texas man
yeah yeah yeah I've had a few times
where I get the really excited girls who
don't know that they can't handle their
alcohol until they get to my show but I
love your journal yeah a brother pupils
yes yeah there it is that's exactly were
you there the Rodriguez family loves you
I get that we love yous and all that and
I get a lot of whoo girls two girls in a
bachelorette party yeah yeah it's the
worst and you try to get them to stop
and then they're like we're just having
fun why are you kicking us out and I
hate older woman was there a green left
you tell them you do they call me number
five
girls this guy man we're gonna be at
this club they story for the after-party
though you're gonna be there right
I do get some of those but rarely and I
think I don't know um if it's maybe just
the vibe that I give off that no I'm not
gonna go to your after-party but it
doesn't I don't get invited too often
after parties I think it's because
people know I'm just gonna go back to my
room and watch Law & Order SVU and so
they're like uh whatever is thanks for
the good shows but but I get after my
shows a lot of girls that want to be my
best friend and I love that that's like
such a compliment to me that after my
show they could hold you like there's a
hotel show they they want me to move to
Tulsa they're like yes come be besties
but it's such a government that you were
able to relate to somebody for an hour
on stage to the point where they're like
oh my god let's be best friends like
that it's a compliment to me for sure I
was surprised to do that one road your
life you you you just spoke my life
right now bro have settled my wife just
like you bro that's what we relate to my
we both don't want her do you do we get
people that go like that um that Judge
you cuz you're a Christian right your
mother's Christian your dad's
questionable raised Catholic yeah my
parents uh raised us Catholic but we
weren't involved in the church too much
I did my first communion no no I got hit
with a lot of other things though but we
did I did my first communion in
catechism and then my parents got
divorced and I guess we weren't allowed
to go to the Catholic Church anymore I'm
not quite sure how that worked out and
then separately they started going to
Christian churches and then so they
started raising a Christian after that
that's that thing bra when I when you're
on you're in a Catholic Church and you
want to get a divorce and the other and
you got to pay the church and if you
don't pay you can't come back to the
church really yeah well what Anna no man
that's only when you get married you pay
a little fee to that church oh wow
yeah and that takes an envelope yeah we
love we're poor chose hopping Catholic
Church should be asking for too much
money I was no watch man again yeah I
mean how many Tyler with a Neil don't
change any more than what dollars for
our churches was a menudo sale at the
church would have money but I gave it
all to you guys I'm priest new there
everybody was hungover bro so far a
great boy could be left in hallelujah uh
what about menudo sing : it was muscle
and then there's people who saw people
those people there that would buy like
never was a menudo sell at church no
there's a Catholic Church people show up
with their own little little pot and
you're a part of oh really put it in
there yeah take off people take a part
of menudo from the menudo sell it how
many gets give me ten to fill it up I'll
fill it up for ten dollars it will be by
cups white really not the power in
menudo
you can train your kids to still
condiments like 40 years
cilantro and onions yeah I don't eat the
tripe but I do like me too though I like
poor soil a better because meat yeah
there's meat that you can actually eat
and not like love the tribe and he's
tried sushi huh the trifecta so how long
how long we were a Raiders trivia for a
year one year yeah doesn't you don't
travel the cheerleader huh no well
so we got to travel to the Super Bowl
that year so that was nice
oh that like when they lost all their
bible i was depressing it was like umm I
remember it was really unbelievable
because if you remember like how many
interceptions were thrown that day it
was like wait this is a joke so it
wasn't like oh close game the beam now
it was like we I remember it's all
looking at each other like what what is
this what what are we doing here what
we're like embarrassed at this it was a
fun experience to be there but it was
embarrassing it was yeah it was bad man
cheerleader were right into resumes
during a game for these a jump off the
porch now that they're watching the game
from the laundromat I'll do my laundry
that's a sad day watching them lose the
Super Bowl at a laundromat
that's sad things give my Newcastle's
and then they drove with my laundry to
Willie Barcena house and everybody was
drunk and sad cold corner so you were on
that guy I never knew this that I'm bon
Qui Qui yes you made up that character
and then I character metaphor MADtv so
you could travel and do whatever you
want with it I don't know it worked that
way at that we made up a character they
keep it well it depends it's um all
different situations for for me
personally the way it was then which I'm
sure now contracts changed with the
whole new media and social media and all
the kind of stuff but at the time it was
you make a list of all your original
characters that you had coming into the
show and so bon Qui Qui was a character
that I actually auditioned for MADtv
with that character and so she was
already established outside of MADtv but
MADtv did blow up her spot and and make
her visual for everybody so
in its very vague but we kind of both
have rights to it
you know but she is my character and and
things like that so I am able to do my
music with her and and we did a record
with Warner Brothers Records I was a
comedic hip-hop album under the
character bon Qui Qui sweet we just
toured with the character this past
summer we did a music tour it was a lot
of fun a comedic music I never never
imagined I would be doing that like when
I was coming to wow coyotes or wherever
we were I would have never been able to
tell you yeah I'm gonna be in the next
13 years touring as a music artist
making people laugh with music I never
thought that would be part of my journey
but it was a lot of fun and we're
looking to do it again this coming
spring and go to some different cities
that we didn't weren't able to hit up
the first round
boy oh yeah could be really bored
quickly give us a bung quickly right now
has literally taken on a life of her own
I like following your face because I
like how you stuff grows on people like
um like watching little book weekly fan
sometimes how sometimes you see like a
fan dresses up their daughter like bug
week we or it's hilarious dog Oh father
life now man that that character spoke
to them you know what that kept his
focus on so much my little daughter will
be born quickly for that day I see
people dress up their kids like Felipe
and gay bro at the same time I met a guy
in Denver who his son looks like Gabriel
s he's fat you know his greasy he's
unhealthy and bad knees you know the Sun
yeah and then his other son
love hair chubby oily face like me you
know he's saying fool all the time he's
eating chips are like no hands just
crunching up the chicken you know I said
wow this guy created his sudden two
characters that wasn't a character
they're playing are they no he just adds
up like his son one of them had long
hair and you're the one doesn't like
Gabriel in purpose on purpose
well what an honor
maybe you come to your show so what what
does that like my your life is this
we're gonna see the edge of the Johnson
World Tour finally not this I do love
Justin it's gonna be here right for me
right right like a world war like the
Victory Tour at the Jacksons
yeah I would love to conquer the world
I'm still working on Cleveland right now
man she's starting out everywhere we
just found out Cleveland stuff no oh my
god radio the whole northeast has no
idea who I am it's so funny I'll talk to
Jo koy about this all the time we'll
call each other and just make fun of
each other like if one of us has a
really good weekend the other one has a
terrible weekend then we definitely rub
it in each others face but so anytime I
do terrible I'll call him right now and
be like oh you're gonna love this
I guess how many tickets I sold this
weekend and he'll be like what like 300
no try again 11 yeah yeah I sold 11
tickets to one of my shows I'll be with
a dealer of pity
well no it's a the improv oh you're
aware Cleveland that one right there by
the ocean that will see right there all
done I don't know I never been there
they wanted to cancel they called me who
is this
this was Tuesday this Tuesday yeah this
was last Tuesday shut up
yeah I've been there man you know funny
when I was there
they give us their listen man we don't
give it tickets away oh no your host got
to do this and that and all that crazy
had 277 people there one time all
giveaways but we didn't reach the boney
because the bonus was to was 300 I said
mama you're gonna let me slide 23 people
Gabriel taught me this one and I didn't
again not knowing how things worked but
I remember there was one weekend where I
had that kind of a deal where it was you
get a bonus at X amount of people being
there and let's say it was at 300 people
being there right and I remember this
one club manager was so shady to me it
was 300 people was my bonus right and
he's like ah 298 you were close I'm not
kidding you I am not kidding you 2
tickets away and I was like and they ran
out of alcohol there and he wouldn't
give me my bonus and I'm like look a
pocket of that serious and I remember
talking to Gabriel Iglesias about it and
he goes so then why didn't you just buy
those two tickets and I said I don't
know I don't know what I'm doing and so
he's the one who taught me he's like
yeah weigh it out what your bonus is if
you gotta get your bonus and your 10
tickets away and you still are gonna
walk away with more bonus than you would
buying the tickets then just buy your
tickets and I was like oh my god that's
so smart I wish I would have knew that
mostly but yeah that that was some shady
stuff so it is jealously can't move
though oh well you were sold out by 10
tickets my team go by um yeah bro
that's a good
yeah that's that's me so many time you
look good man you were just shy you
could have sold out but we gave away
these tickets
you really didn't meet the bonus mmm-hmm
anyway they can do wow they must have
made wow that's crazy you would draw
that because I would throw that too but
I didn't thought that it was just me -
you were you already you know is that
Wow because I know that then you were
shy that much 298 that means the club
made a killing in food and alcohol you
shouldn't let that slide oh of course
they should have ethic you you as it
would have said oh my gosh um we want
you to come back to our club let me go
ahead and give you the boat and Irie man
you know who did this for me
what's his name at Ontario improv um the
manager yeah Josh no before Josh
Clark Clark cool Clark was so amazing to
me I remember when I first heard this to
me probably two weekends before this
club manager did this to me right so it
was like two weekends before that I was
doing Ontario and Clark I was probably a
good 45 tickets away from the bonus and
he said you know what I'm gonna give you
this because we want you to come back to
our club so just like as a sign of good
faith here here's your bonus because we
want you to remember us and come back to
our club as I okay great so that's the
way it should be done you know what I
mean this flow over here is that ah too
close hail now or sometimes there's
places where you know you're gonna do
well but they say how about for just
I'll bring her in on Tuesday night first
good evening like they know like you
know you do well another play that'll be
the beginning oh I could come in on the
weekends so it has to sell out Tuesday
night at the DCM progress before they'll
give you a weekend yeah yeah that I'm
sure you know during a Wednesday night
oh right
and then okay yeah we'll bring them back
and we'll bring you back but we're
a different percentage from that one day
though I know on that one day you got
75% of the door while we're gonna you're
saying if I'm in a door every night
mm-hmm
so then it changes now they know if
you're gonna sell if you can sell out
100% of the tickets on Wednesday and
we're giving you 75% of the door we're
not gonna give you that much for the
whole Friday and Saturday you're crazy
40% of the door yeah you have to just
put your foot down and you say no and
then you you let them weigh it out do
they want to lose you you know like you
saw what I did on a Tuesday or a
Wednesday and yeah you're gonna be
taking a risk giving me a whole weekend
but that's the risk you take but I'm not
coming unless you give me the same
percentage if they say no then you move
on you go to the next club and somebody
will give you that and you'll start
building it eventually but yeah but no I
still like I said there's some markets
where I'll sell out a show if I put the
tickets on sale right now and I'll go
there tomorrow they'll sell out Chicago
nope not sure I do well in Chicago but I
that's not one of my I got a guy that
you could work with that you could every
time you got your cargo you're gonna say
wow I am shocked that this happened I
know this promoter named Mikey oh and
I'm a headline there Joe's bar how many
people how many people that host 300 but
with them it's a it's a it's one of the
rooms where it could be more if they
take out all the seats cousin Norman
yeah it's like a boss of Blues yeah but
this guy named Mikey oh he has a mailing
list I mean he knows how to reach
Latinos he does Street Market he was he
goes old school
he hired I saw flyers he does posters he
does radio and you don't even even ever
do Mancow - okay and I went there and I
sold out three shows and I never been
there in my life and I didn't want to do
say knees I didn't want to go to that
far club that's all the way from
Chicago Samberg so yeah man and then he
had asked me man who do you be hard to
bring Angela Johnson I say I don't know
man Chappell Chappell doesn't state the
state theater
but um yeah man or Mikey Oh hook you up
thank you very the man hey Mikey oh if
you're listening up my joke we did um
wow I didn't know that cuz I know places
where you kill you could kill like I
know you're there put it this way this
you wanna know where you'll kill father
where Baby Bash goes they put somebody
call me anatomy and it goes Felipe yo
dawg I want to bring you to Yakima
Washington I never heard of Yakima I
don't know who's there
I caught a baby bash I say man what's
the with Yakima oh man Yakima I've been
going there for the last ten years
Halla Baskins and then yeah man have you
ever been there but that's the Northwest
Hill it over there man
I've done Seattle before and like I said
there's some markets where I could kill
it and sell out a big huge theater and
then there's other markets where I I'm
still building and still and it's it's
crazy how I can do one weekend where
I'll sell out completely and the next
weekend I'll go to a builder market and
it's this weekend I'm doing Cleveland
and they wanted to council it because I
wasn't selling tickets there and I was
like no I want to I wanted to keep this
show because I'm trying to work on new
material
I need my our premieres this Friday on
Netflix so once that comes out on Friday
all that material is now old but I'm
still using it you know what I mean so
it's like crap I need to build new
materials so no we're gonna keep this
weekend and it's just gonna be real
rough on my ego but real good for my act
you know and I'm gonna work on some new
stuff and build some new stuff and try
some new stuff you post a photo of that
audience so I watched it what photo that
one you post up and
Pittsburgh today everybody knows man it
ain't all good everywhere I go oh no no
yes improv posted on Sunday we have 45
people but they all paid all right
Pittsburgh
till this day now Cleveland's about to
take the rain but Pittsburgh was my
worst weekend of my entire career
worst and best because I had the best
time I had so much fun when I was there
we went tailgating one of the games like
we had such a good time hung out with
the staff at the club and we had so much
fun that weekend but that was a weekend
where I sold 17 tickets
everything else was comps like it it was
bad so but that weekend I grew so much
as a comedian because I can get very
scripted where I know what joke comes
after this joke comes after this joke
and just stick to my life with a
humbling week no it was humbling for
sure and I get afraid to take risks I
get afraid to try something new because
I know what works so let me just stick
to this you know if I have a sold-out
crowd I don't want to try something new
and disappoint people let me just give
them my hitters because they all paid to
get here you know so now I'm in this
crowd where there's maybe 30 people in
the room everybody hates me it feels
like you know what I mean and so I was
like well you know what let me just try
new things let me just flip my act
around and I remember I did my act
backwards and I did everything that I
closed with I did it right in the
beginning and just flipped it just to
try something different cuz that was the
first we'll realize that the last will
be first I was right well you drop
inside so it was the best and worst
weekend because I had sold no tickets it
was 17 tickets unbelievable unreal it
was humiliating but at the same time I
grew so much that weekend and it was so
valuable and I took that with me so I
knew this fall
I booked a lot of shows and markets
where I know I have no fan base there
for the purpose of building my act and
building my market there too even though
I only sold 11 tickets in Cleveland
those 11 people are gonna bring a friend
and tell them about next time and then
next year I'll sell twenty two tickets
so it'll be great
that's what's so cool oh yeah dropping
mad knowledge right here Angela that's
what's up man so ain't always greener
still gotta be mowed fertilized worked
on how you doing Florida I do pretty
well in Florida Orlando is always good
huh the south
I do really well in the South Orlando I
do well Tampa Tampa Jacksonville I do
pretty well in the south it's it's the
Northeast I have a hard time with yeah
man how about Boise been to Boise Idaho
I have I think I did I have I have a lot
of family in Idaho we don't know that oh
you know what I did I did Spokane which
was right next to Idaho so I just
Washington and I have a lot of family
lives in Idaho so I remember they all
drove in like 30 minutes
to Spokane so I don't know maybe I know
I've done Idaho I have I have I did well
mhm
you got that people who tell you I flew
so we drove seven yeah yep we drove in
from Montana we hit a deer on the way
over how come you don't come to Montana
I'll try is there any way you're gonna
make it to why mama Florida that's what
some people tell me there's a lot of
Mexicans over here why mama bro all
right bro get a big-ass van and drive
over there yeah yeah they're the big
lots will meet you yeah howdy caddy for
everybody and you know what I find that
I have an issue with because I am I am a
Latino and I am a comedian that a lot of
times promoters or Booker's
are like Oh Latino comedian and then
I'll get my press itinerary and it's
like all these Spanish stations and I'm
like okay one I don't speak Spanish
okay to my demographic isn't really
Spanish speaking Latinos and I even I
know that
yeah it's it's English speaking from
Latinos Filipinos white people soccer
moms soccer Midwest radio station are
they listening to them that's why I need
to yeah yeah soccer moms love me but
they're like oh she's a Latina
let's do always get yeah I'm sorry
what'd you say so you do well I really
do well the DC in DC yeah listen DC is a
good comedy town I need pretty well
there however Martha's vineyard's bone
um funny bone you know funny budget me
that I'm trying to remember the places
produce it was empty production
essential show back in the day no bro no
I just do these shows were with these
two guys named Tony Sanchez and March in
Moreno and they should have a shorter or
in Orange County and in one time it just
started dying out because it did every
week and in Joe Diaz said all man is
horrible they're cheap productions I'm
trying to remember the last time
Pittsburgh was dead you know people
I'm going to Pittsburgh next month -
it's gonna be the same thing I am an was
tough man like an original bonus with
Nayak and which was nice
I'm going there - have you already done
it I've done that I'm three years ago
with Rodrigo Torres we got snowed in
we missed us Friday night two shows but
the next day people showed up there's a
lot of people were there who know who I
am but they what they don't they don't
want to leave their comfort zone of the
Queens to drive an hour or two hour bus
to go to West Nyack into the woods but
um New York I have a tough time with - I
do well but not really well like I I do
Gotham in an actual Manhattan I do
Manhattan this is my first time doing
outside of Manhattan so when I do my
hand I do Gotham and that Club is small
it's like 250 275 I have been I've done
it five times now and I'll do it like
every 15 months to two years I'll come
back there and I've done it like five
times I have not once sold out a week in
there
I've sold out shows but not a weekend
you know what I mean and that's a small
club so I'm still building New York like
it's still it's not on and poppin for me
like a Texas or you know where Arizona
well I get you know Taylor parent either
Perry show Wendy Williams a I would be
what mister power people know your how
to build your career just before they
watch one engineer you should have had
your own straw man not that shake on
Channel seven I swear my be following
you since day one yeah I quote
everything you do I nicknamed my
daughter bon Qui Qui people always say
that Philippe you should have been there
fool up there I know I stood up bro yeah
I should've bro but then I'm the guy who
won that cover standing I'm glad that
happen yeah yeah yeah oh thank you for
time people to vote for me by the way
yeah Angela Johnson told people to vote
for me when I was on Last Comic Standing
Russell Peters
and Gabriel is did it within two hours
people that's why they have a Chinese or
but it sounds like you know Vietnamese
when you're doing it the way you do the
accent it's all dial it don't really say
no no no yeah I count to ten I count to
ten Vietnamese and I say Happy New Year
and I say thank you and then I just make
up words that sound like those words
that are similar to those words that's
what I do
are you not allowed at no shops along
the way some some love me some hate me
do they know who you are they do they
they don't that's the one there's been
times where I have been recognized and
it's a friendly situation and then
there's times where it's not a friendly
situation hostile talk like that not
hostile just it got real shady real
quick I was in Orlando Florida I went
into a nail salon and the girl I went to
get a mani-pedi right so I started my
manicure and she's doing my manicure and
um she got real cold all of a sudden
just like not friendly and she's she's
talking to them in Vietnamese about me
clearly and I'm like okay maybe she
recognizes me or something and she's
like being a little rough with my hands
you know like just filing like real
rough and I'm like huh that's weird
she's saying something to the girls in
the back and I hear one of the girls in
the back pull out her phone and she to
have her volume down and I hear her pull
up the video the nail salon video so as
soon as she pulls it up and she turn
down right so clearly this salon was not
a fan of that joke so as soon as my
manicure was done I was like okay I'm
done thanks I'm not hanging my pedicure
here that's okay thank you and I just
paid and I left and that just little
situations like that were clearly
they're not fans
but then I've had other salons where my
extra finger on you oh oh yeah yeah yeah
they gave me some extras and I talked I
talked about it in my new hour special
where I say like the aftermath of what's
happened since then and I had this one
time where I was at a salon the lady was
doing my pedicure and she looked at me
and she said what your name and it was
yeah it wasn't like the typical friendly
way that they do it like hi honey what
your name you know like that it was
really it was it was checking me it was
what your name right and I was like oh
snap and I was I was with my mom and my
sister and so I kind of just like look
over at them like oh it's about to go
down right now
and I said Angela and she just looks at
me and she goes that would at that I
didn't know was she gonna like cut my
toe at this point like how was this
situation going to progress but she and
they this salon was actually a fan and
they liked the joke okay and so at that
point she was like that way I thought I
knew I think you come here I say that
girl they say they know and then they
all start talking then they're all like
happy and they're all about it but it's
night and day from the first situation
where they are not about it and this one
they're like come back again October 2
people are Netflix the one-hour special
and the constant what's the title of
your special not fancy oh yeah oh man
it'll be awesome so you know that's good
you're doing that so this is like it's
like a good toilet
let your fans know what happened after
the whole no thing
we were wanting to know so crazy Jerry
minds want to know
that's cool man that you're so honest
you know like I don't keep it real man
nah they're just selling on every year
every show is sold out you know keeping
it 100 my farts smell like Cologne yeah
yeah but yeah wow I thought you were
really tired that you were selling out
like all over the world like your world
famous you know man just follow were
very bad goal you should know I've only
done new faces and ethnic shows you hear
new faces in Montreal no I think that's
it good I know you'll do well in Toronto
I would like to go there that [ __ ]
Toronto been and they like you there yes
that with Russell Peters all over Canada
well see I say if you work with Russell
then yeah they're gonna like you
I with Russell then I dig the I went
back to do a show at the underground
cafe with puff mama mama that was the
first club every day what they had bombs
in every table everybody was smoking
bombs when I was in Canada it was
private just inside this place was
private huh everybody's loud you know up
joins and I'm not lighting up nothing
maybe because you know I want to I don't
repeat jokes I'll do my job first
so once the game with a light a cell
right man
game over man so yeah member one time
man when I was doing really really
horrible in life which was not so long
ago yes I want to do a horrible life but
you know when you're doing horrible in
life you feel like life life is kicking
your butt man like I was all tore up I
was getting drunk all the time
and then remember I was the other I hung
out with you I don't know you saw me
once some time at the improv and I
remember you wrote me this nice letter
about how does quit smoking weed yeah
yes you have it in my having at home she
wrote Angela Johnson wrong limit nice it
was total nice okay
only one of my notebook out how to quit
smoking weed he was first okay good yeah
okay good cuz I believed in you
yes very carried that sounds like me I
didn't know where are you going with it
though I didn't yeah you were like
judging me it was good it was actually
good somebody cared actually yeah I was
just a mission
yeah you should say that to you and
Edwin yeah you wouldn't stop man annoyed
we're not just be like I got arthritis
Angela whether cigarettes to she said um
I don't remember the bullet points of
that of that note the one I said about
how I should smoke how I should stop
smoking weed you know the first time
somebody said you start off by picking
one day out of the week did you know
gonna smoke weed then from that point on
you fight you picture there the week
that you're not gonna want one week and
you never to buy no weight at all that
week I'm so cute and very and um you
know just dump quit for a whole month
and I remember I went that whole week
she said I got to the power sink don't
smoke don't buy no way for a whole week
I bought a shitload of weed before I did
the whole week
did I just stop did quit drinking you
got you got a lot left in you you just
care about you that's all that's it man
yes I want you to kill any so this new
special how long did it take for you to
write for listeners out there people who
think they want to do calm
don't if you think about doing comedy
right now during this interview I
suggest you just don't you know what it
takes before you never know blow up on
YouTube it's done it's done
people do that how they think that well
she did I could do it now broad the
timings but you gotta answer it like
karl-oskar does bro bro the timings bad
bro it is your time it is your time yo I
wasn't there no Kolkata the Oscars
either get comedian we had and um he
just broke it down like you know it's
not it's gonna take time bro for you to
make your bros gonna take time at your
time and a couple predictions that came
true though doc yeah so this special you
roryontheroad yeah I leave Lee now
already Alan in Pittsburgh I write on
the road yeah let's see my last special
I did was 2011 I think those photos oh
no TV or CTV Nouveau nubile some Spanish
yeah yeah man we're trying to find out
everywhere men knew I think now they're
fuse TV or some other views yeah I think
that's what it is I was trying to find
what that fuse was of something else
that special you did for Nouveau mm-hmm
the death special goal to Netflix or
that special it's on I think it's on
Netflix now I think it is now I live for
free no no Filipa don't let somebody
tell you that's a good idea
um well okay so the way that one worked
is I I didn't have a vision for that
special like I did for my first hour
special for my first hour I knew what I
was talking about I knew the story I was
telling I knew how I wanted it to look
the message I was giving how the market
I knew everything I wanted that special
this
second special I did was more so where I
was like okay I have an hour of material
and I'm starting to cycle some things
out so let me document this and record
another hour so I think it was we
pitched around and we finally got a
production company to buy my hour
special and so we shot it and then they
pitched it to different people and Nuvo
is the one who bought it because we were
just gonna end up going straight to DVD
and the Nuba ended up buying it and then
I think now it is on Netflix so that was
2011 what is it 12 30 40 50 so was there
three four years time flies boom yeah
yeah yeah four years I guess to write
three or four years to write my next
hour I guess I took something like that
I don't know I can't remember 2011 or 12
okay then it was 11 when I shot it
because it took about a year
uh-huh yep yeah your wife he knows a lot
of stuff you guys need a lot of stuff
yeah you guys are really good at knowing
things you remember everything you know
everything I love it yeah so about three
years to write a new hour what did you
recorded one hour special my new one in
the Grove of Anaheim awesome mm-hmm
I did the one I did to show it there for
the TV and the one before that was San
Jose Bravo or some crap okay so whatever
at the improv man with the last manager
heard of the big fight you and Jim how
do you know that I know everything how
do you never talks I've let him do
nothing with the management I don't hang
around with the improv I don't hang
around with managers I don't hang around
with owners of clubs we don't have lunch
because they tell everybody everything I
just gotta ask who's here last week tell
me what happened yeah well so remember
the story I told you earlier in the
podcast about oh you're - away from a
sellout oh really
that was Jim that was funny because you
say that because when I went to the
Improv when I went
this other club they told me ma'am you
go to the other club make sure you count
everything oh now we'll see polish or
with a counter otherwise polish or
heaven counter what is the other
community is standing in a bag I
realized when they were telling me our
you know polisher he cares the people
count I used to do that to understand
why but then I realized oh wait a minute
this guy gave away fifty-five comps when
he wasn't supposed to yeah yeah and it's
every its comps it's um your bonuses and
things like that and I've had I used to
do clickers a lot and then I started
doing more theaters and you don't count
the theaters but now that we're doing
clubs again I'll probably start bringing
the clicker out again but it's it yeah
exactly
it's um keeping the club accountable and
it's just letting them know that you're
watching one and that they can't pull
one over on you so already it's a mind
game it's it's like hey we're friendly
we're coming in here everybody who I
roll with number one is professional is
friendly
we're not rude we're not entitled we're
not demanding anything well that's
everybody that I roll into okay so it's
like is we come in friendly and we're
like hey we're here to do business and
you're here to do business that's that's
great let's work together you know what
I mean and some people are shady some
people are not and you learn who is who
by the end of the weekend so we would
come with our clicker and we my former
assistant would count every person in
there so by the end it was capacity is
350 right and so they were paying me for
350 tickets but she counted that there's
372 people in here so those extra
tickets where'd that money come from we
need to make sure you add that and in
the end you know what I mean so it's
like well our capacity is 350 and you
sold out every show so here's your your
your check it's like okay but you
stuffed in an extra 30 people per show
so where's that money you know what I
mean and so it's that's why you count
your rooms it's to get your bonuses
you know things like that so it's a
again learning situation that I learned
from watching other comedians and
hearing how things go
but yeah back to uh what's-his-name at
the San Jose improv that was one of my
first experiences with him and just many
many other things where he just really
tried to like ruin my character and like
like spit on my character and who I am
as a person and spread that around to
other clubs about me and I remember I
had done she wanted blankets oh yeah I
have a blanket my writer because I get
cold in the greenroom its : oh yeah I'm
not gonna travel with a big old blanket
on on the airplane everywhere no so just
can you just prepare to put a little
blanket my groom thank you
but anyways he he basically made it
sound like I was a huge huge diva to
other clubs and and stuff like that and
I remember I had did I done his weekend
at San Jose improv we sold out eight
shows at the San Jose Improv damn it was
insane it was insane the very next
weekend was my Pittsburgh week and I
just told you about which was my worst
and best weekend because I only sold 11
tickets or 17 tickets that weekend so I
went from San Jose to a very humbling
Pittsburgh the very next weekend but
when I got there we're just you know
hanging out with everybody taking me to
radio and stuff like that and I remember
hearing one of the staff say wow you're
nothing like the email that San Jose
sent over what yeah and I was like I'm
sorry what what did they say and then
all of a sudden the the it was lost they
couldn't find it what he said you know
they realized they just got caught but
he basically Snowden told them watch out
for me I'm a diva and blah blah blah and
all this kind of stuff and they're like
yeah you're nothing like what he said I
was a What did he say
and so like that was like strike three
that with the past and just other little
things that he would do that we're real
just why what is wrong
people do that she's so nice so I told
cuz I have a really good relationship
with the improv so I told them I'm I'm
not going back to the sounds the improv
as long as he's the Manager and I never
went back for I think six years or
something and I ended up doing the San
Jose Performing Arts Center a couple
times and I would not go back to the
improv because of Jim and then he left
and I came back and solo 11 shows before
hopefully what's up for chili
new questions or what now I'm clean will
you at this week Cleveland yep Cleveland
Cleveland Ypres got no manage any
listeners out there man from the Midwest
you know go check her out man because
you know the night Sheena Sheena one of
those comics then they're gonna put her
on that whack ass job Bob and Tom so so
you gotta got our promoter support as a
Johnson and Cleveland people hey sure
those Midwestern radio shows um I don't
know me neither man tell me the last
time I went to the Midwest besides
Chicago Indiana in the appleís at the
time I did them I think well no right
for me you have a beautiful Chicago
drove over there yeah those were my fans
yeah so just go back to Chicago I was
trip out man I wanna do a club oh it
doesn't happen to more but because I
look I check it out now but for the all
your head liners out there who are
listening man this might happen to you
like you look at the contract and then
you see this guy spent that much on
advertisement but I don't see it anymore
huh I don't see it anywhere
yeah where's the Billboard yeah yep so
what Lisa and I do what we do my wife
and I and I go to a place in where it's
tough you know like okay like tampa
orlando i sent an email out listen man
if you have a business this goes out to
people out there right now if you have a
business out there right now and you
want to promote my show and put a poster
that i'm coming to your town I will
give you four tickets to Thursday okay
for ticket to Thursday or Sunday whoever
yeah and you get in man and I will
promote yes I will promote your shows on
the Internet of amour your shows on Oh
on my page man on everybody no manage
your barbershop hold it up and that's
how I do it good and they show up man
happy on Thursday for the [ __ ] good so
yo you want to tell us about more shows
are coming up that's actually a really
smart idea I should probably hit up
every hair salon they'll do it all by
the way Angela and and Yakama all my
tickets are sold through beauty salons
really yes the guy who promotes is a
woman she owns a beauty salon people go
there for hair extensions
mm-hm and they get their nails done too
and they buy those some weird women's
clothes only women know about and they
do they do eyebrows man and the whole
time those pliers are my show and the
lady sells tickets there and the women
are going oh my god my husband love
Felipe i'ma buy four tickets
mm-hmm so just to let you know man
beauty salons and in Cleveland the word
it's funny I do the opposite where I do
sports radio stations because I know
that these wives tell their husbands
about this like nail salon joke and the
babe it's so true
blah blah blah so I'll get a lot of
husbands at my show they're like oh yeah
she tells me all the time this and that
whatever so I'll do sports stations and
a lot of times like oh that's the girl
my wife likes I'm gonna get two tickets
you know that kind of thing no but what
you got coming up man this Saturday Ice
House stage two with Juan Garcia I'll be
there and if you guys need exterminating
hit me up through Instagram and Twitter
my papers low right now have a word with
mando for two weeks except for today but
let me know if you guys got roaches rats
don't let you know nobody buddy
yeah donator a hair german yo man we
have an exterminator I have a very close
relationship with my exterminator
had I known had I known um I hate
spiders
uh I don't know if you follow me on
Instagram or anything but if I have an
encounter with the spider I'm gonna post
it and I just recently moved and we live
up in the hills now where my backyard is
basically a forest and so I have a lot
of spiders everywhere like I walk out of
my door and I just walked through a
spiderweb
like that's my life now so I've had
exterminators out my house once a month
they'll come out and I we're on self
like I text him pictures I'm like bro
what is this I just found this he's like
oh it's just a wolf spider don't worry
about it I'll show you picture the
spider I just found I had a brown
recluse house
really yeah and California no yeah there
is there is because of travel yeah yeah
I know
that's crazy I almost died I must die to
have a bunch of praying mantis I'm house
freaking everything what are those
silverfish yeah those things everywhere
spiders I found a spider that was like
black and white polka dotted legs and a
red body cuz I'm crazy
oh yeah and ie in LA area only by the
way anybody want some exterminating
gunman was a roaches smoke well Gina
Torres is your man yeah give you a free
podcast taker even walk around bro just
get mad and just start exterminating for
free right people I'm gonna be at the
parlor bar-parlour live in Seattle
Washington first time headlining their
Seattle by the way okay man October 8
through 10 Seattle Washington
October 22nd through 25th West Nyack New
York San Antonio Texas November 5/5
through the AIDS finally they got rid of
the stinking condo over there
Brownsville Texas and McAllen Texas
27:28 Thanksgiving weekend New Year's
Eve Ontario improv man before you go
marry that I ask you man what the worst
comedy condo you've been to it I know
you can
in the beginning you couldn't avoid them
well my first nah my worst comedy condo
experience it happened one time before I
was like the management me in
rinky-dinky Marriott before you put me
in a comedy condo now because at least I
know housekeeping came in and cleaned so
I was in this comedy condo I think it
was in Denver and I went to get in the
bed and comic there there was the guy
who was there before me I forget who it
was but it was a guy comedian before me
but in the bed was makeup all over the
the pillowcases in the sheets and I
remember thinking sick one you didn't
have somebody come clean the sheets from
his groupie scenario and I'm about to
get in this bed right now
hail no I almost got into a know a
groupie fest in bed I almost had to call
you to come in Stern exterminate off the
bed it was disgusting but yeah a long
time ago Oh Mac those I was in Denver at
that club last week at that condo
surprise the best comedy card or the
whole world it's a nice condo it's a
nice condo save one the one that has is
real big a colossal yeah it's uh maybe
it's different then it was a nice condo
but it's uh so you did Comedy Works in
Larimer Square no in downtown yeah yeah
downtown Denver square and it's like
maybe two blocks away in a high-rise
building yeah it's a high-rise building
both in the second floor they changed
they might have changed it yeah this one
looks like I'm in a set of the MTV room
nice no this was this was older it was
nice it was big but it was older and had
mascara on the sheets
so yeah she's live she stood to cry
funny
so what so fool you have any more dates
you want to tell our listeners yeah I
will be in ok you how about you just
tell my Cleveland this weekend Baltimore
October 17th weekend I bought some more
urine now timonium timoni oh really
we were there tomorrow that jukebox
McGoo be but groupies Magoo bees are my
boobies boobies boobies the old it real
cool ok drive you around where we wanna
go magoo bees and then the San Jose
improv was intense
levity live I'm doing them November 6/7
bring a jacket
Oh yep Pittsburgh improv Chicago improv
that's it and then Tommy T's for New
Year's yeah man Tommy momma take your
radio right now man you don't mind I
brought my dog how was your wife you
know she's gorgeous
like the whole family that you have a
reality show they get together before
the show this is the lies we're gonna
tell the comedian's right a little a
little penguin around a little pain yeah
a little piggy yeah it's cute little
pale we picked that fool up man he's so
wrong look I'm vegan though man so I
should like this pillow that look
Bulldog too for a while
yeah man a little pig reading just so
slobbering it's to overlord with a
pot-bellied pig
yeah so what's up fool you have two days
to Portugal Angela Johnson anything else
anybody and check out her special this
Friday on Netflix
check out her special on Netflix people
and also man take photos of it on
Instagram and post it up yeah
know what the hell you're watching and
they go oh man I don't know Angela just
an especial everyday just tell somebody
go watch the special that's right
hashtag Angela Johnson I'll fight as
tight as you Johnson that was the Jay
people all right that's right and je lah
yeah man yeah yeah anything else fool
that's it also people if you want Elm if
you have lice in your house or ants
what's so fool your baby's head